I'm here to tell you the story of the
accidental discovery of artificial dyes
the William Henry Perkin discovered
movin in 1856 he was trying to make
Quinny
instead of making Quin een Perkin ended
up with a black powder but he didn't
throw the black powder away he
experimented on it and found that he
could use it to dye fabric purple here
we have a sample of fabric dyed with
moving that was used to make a dress
worn by Queen Victoria in 1860 after
Perkin made movie a kaleidoscope of
artificial dives began to appear on the
markets however as with many new
scientific developments there were
teething problems these artificial dyes
would fade easily as can be seen here in
this sample of cotton fabric that was
dyed with moving in 1860 you can see the
spots where the dye has faded the
chemical structure of the artificial
dyes was fairly unstable and the dyed
material would fade in the sunlight
James Morton had inherited a family
textile company to test how well dyed
fabric lasted Under the Sun James Morton
sent some samples of fabric out to his
brother-in-law who lived in India
Morton instructed his brother-in-law to
leave samples of different fabrics on
the roof of his house in the full glare
of sun lights what Morton found in these
experiments is that some dyes lasted
better under the Sun than others so here
you can see a selection of dyes that
lasted quite well under the Sun but he
found that some dyes and here we've got
a sample of his competitors dyes they
didn't last very well under the Sun at
all in fact you can barely recognize
them so Morton looked at which dyes
lasted better when placed in full
sunlight and got his chemist John
Christy to make dyes based on those
results
[Music]
Morton marketed his dives to high-end
fashion chains like Burberry's and
Liberty's he marketed them based on the
fact that his dyes would not fade and
here we see an advert placed by burr
breweries in the Queens magazine the
queen magazine was quite a high-end
magazine and you can see that they're
advertising dyed fabrics where the dyes
are indelible they won't fade in
sunlight you can even see a reference
here to the experiments that James
Morton made in India from Perkins
accidental discovery of moving to
Morton's mission to find dyes that would
not fade the objects here tell the story
of the relationship between chemistry
and fashion subscribe to the science
museum channel to watch more stories
from the stores and discover other
fascinating science stories